well brent it may be unconventional but
you made it to the final round of this
competition
you're going to go head to head against
a smith whose current record is seven
wins and zero losses oh i'm gonna see if
you have what it takes to beat the
unbeaten
ben abbott
france big surprise
brent and i have been friends ever since
that first episode
it's a hell of a time
i know he's an amazing smith so i'm
gonna have to go all out plus a little
to keep the streak going
well boy smith i gotta say guys i am
thoroughly thrilled about this
competition not only because we got two
talented smiths here but because you
guys have a little bit of history you
know each other you've worked side by
side before and i'm very very excited to
see you guys battle it out in the next
eight hours gentlemen you will be going
head to head in a blade spinning
competition where you need to make a
blade from start to finish
now as you guys can see dave and doug
are not gonna be joining us for this
round for fairness they're not gonna
have a clue whose blade is who's when
they get into testing
now brent because you won the last round
you were able to choose whatever blade
you wanted from our fortune fire vault
that you wanted yourself and ben to
build
so for the next eight hours you are both
going to be working diligently to build
this
the ida sword
the iba sword used by the yaruba people
of west africa features a double-edged
leaf-shaped blade ideal for harvesting
crops in the fields as well as
inflicting lethal slashes and stabs in
battle
this deadly weapon appeared in season 4
of fortune fire
where both smiths produce ornate
damascus patterns but one smith's
mistake during his quench caused the
sword to chip during the strength test
costing him the competition
your time starts now so as my billet's
coming up to heat in the forge i'm
working on forging out my wrought iron
this feels really solid really good but
i have to move on because i know that
this sword build is going to take
every minute that i have this is a
critical moment because i've got to have
good welds there we go
it looks good it's not splitting apart
at the ends in any significant way
and i'm really happy with it see if it
works the center spine that i've forged
in on my tooling is not really straight
it's very lumpy but i have so much to do
i have to move on
this is a critical moment
because this is the moment where this
thing becomes a sword
it's warped so i'm going straight to the
leg vice to start to look at
straightening i don't love that i'm
pulling on this blade back and forth to
bend it into the correct shape
okay
stick with that
i've got a really warpy blade but
i still have a lot of mass on this blade
so i can grind a little off of this side
a little off of that and find a center
that's straight
i take my blade out of the temper and i
realize that i've got to get this handle
going i want to make sure that it
indexes well and it's not too round i
want those judges to feel like it was
shaped proportionate to their hands just
wanted to be comfortable for them to use
and safe of course
i finally get the thing shaped up
i just grab that handle and feel that
sword and this moment is the first
moment i've felt like a sword it's great
after the welts are set i get the billet
to length now it's time to start
grinding all of that scale off of both
sides of that bullet so that i can cut
it and restack it all i've got now is
one more weld to get the wrought iron
and nickel stuck onto this bullet and
i'm off to the races this is both the
scariest and most fun part about this
build if the weld doesn't stick it would
be catastrophic this world has to take
now i'm relatively confident that this
bullet is welded
the next step is to cut the shoulders
for the bolster where the bolster
matches up to the handle and my first
squeeze is on the tang side of what's
going to be my bolster i have to be
really careful here because it could end
up being a weak spot it could break so
i'm paying a very close attention to
make sure i don't over squeeze that
junction between bolster and blade now
it's time for the quench
i don't want to lose
i've given all the time i can give to
the blade and the acid it's now time to
take a look
[Music]
dude
it looks awesome man i see the nickel i
see the wrought iron in the center i'm
super excited it's just a matter of the
last little bits now
five
four three
two
one great work please put down your
blades and prepare yourselves for
testing all right bladesmiths welcome to
the dynamic keel test
find out how lethal your ida swords are
i'm gonna cut through this but the six
dummy and four coins you guys ready yes
sir all right let's do this
[Music]
all right guys the first thing about
this is when you pick it up it's forward
heavy because you have thicker grinds
right here
but when you swing it it's manageable i
like the flare that he put over there
because it's really giving me a nice
counter balance especially when you're
swinging something that has a forward
weight to it
overall
it will kill
[Music]
all right gentlemen when i pick up this
blade
i can feel the distribution of the
weight be far more even compared to
golds over here when i'm cutting this
because of that distribution
it's even a deeper chop into this
ballistics dummy now when i'm grabbing
onto the handle here actually it feels
good it's a void i can really tell where
the edge is
overall
it will kill
all right gentlemen it's time for our
combined strength and sharpness test the
ammo crate chop and foam dummy slice
gold animals up
so
right off when you pick up this weapon
there's a lot of weight up here in this
blade but in that test
the blade took a warp right there
as far as the edges of the blade go
they held up quite well but uh there's
really no getting around that bend
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this thing is a superior
cutter those cuts took maybe half the
effort to get deeper into that target as
far as the strength test goes
it took no damage
nice piece
well blaze missed in eight hours you
were both tasked to build a very
difficult blade with an even more
difficult technique but in this
competition only one of you can come out
on top the winner of today's fortune
fire competition is
ben abbott you are now eight and oh
buddy congratulations oh brent well i
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor
i was able to do something pretty
incredible i think in eight hours but
ben's a whole another level it looks
like he took four days on it like a
normal challenge unbelievable i'm a
two-time loser
ben ben ben holy current record of 8-0
in the forge how are you feeling i feel
amazing i am
super excited
brent is such an amazing smith and to be
able to pull up a win
against him
i just feel absolutely amazing but here
i am still undefeated with any luck i'll
be able to keep this streak alive for uh
ever and a day there's a lot of smiths
out there that might want to take me
down but uh i'm here i'm ready bring it
on
you